Jessica Gallaher used to work for Fox
News radio and she's currently suing Fox
for gender discrimination and I actually
am NOT interested in talking about the
gender discrimination lawsuit I'm more
interested in talking about some of the
assertions she made when speaking to a
group of British lawmakers and citizens
in Parliament recently about Trump Fox
and Russia
Jessica gollaher told a group of UK
lawmakers and citizens that Fox would
not allow her to go to Moscow to
investigate possible connections between
Donald Trump and Russia even when she
offered to pay her own way going on to
say quote Fox is just buying what the
White House is selling this really
should not come as much of a surprise
because we learned earlier this year
that Donald Trump colluded with Fox News
to take attention away from his ties to
Russia so it really is all par for the
course she offered to pay her own way
she's a journalist and she wanted to do
an investigative bit of journalism and
Fox News still told her no and this
might also mean and this is really what
I think we need to be exploring this
also suggests that someone at Fox News
within that food chain fears that if all
of a sudden
Jessica gollaher or whoever else starts
digging into Trump Russia that they will
find things because if everybody was
satisfied that she would find nothing
why would they try to stop her
from paying her own way to investigate
this and I actually feel really terrible
for Jessica gollaher because I am sure
that as a result of the publicity that
she's getting because of these
assertions she is going to start getting
the trolls and the death threats and the
entire thing and the real bigger
question that surfacing is to what
extent is Fox News wrapped into whatever
Trump Russia collusion there may have
been because this is so unsurprising
that it probably won't get as much
attention as it deserves which is really
sad if you have higher-ups at Fox News
saying I am going to go out of my way
to prevent Jessica gollaher even-even
from spending her own money to go and
investigate this has Fox been directed
by someone at the Trump administration
to prevent serious investigation into
that story is Fox directly in touch with
Russia or Russian agents or individuals
what are the connections because this is
very very weird and what we can be sure
of at this point is that other than
Shepard Smith some of the time and Chris
Wallace a little bit at the time less
time than Shepard Smith we're dealing
with what is effectively in 2017 state
media with Fox News RT recently had to
register as a foreign agents for their
American media presence Fox News seems
to be colluding with or working with or
in in an in some kind of implicit
agreement although maybe it's an
explicit explicit agreement let's assume
it's implicit at least for now with Fox
News to push certain narratives and
think back to the Seth rich case right
the timing of Fox News's discussion of
that case until of course Shepard Smith
eventually said hey this is nothing and
the usefulness of that reporting to
Donald Trump and taking attention away
from I don't even remember at this point
whatever scandal was going on at the
time that timing was suspicious this is
very suspicious and increasingly we need
to consider whether Fox News we know
that it's not fair in balance but we
need to consider whether there is some
kind of actual working relationship here
between Fox News Donald Trump and
whatever interests may be connected to
Russia in this broader investigation
again maybe maybe I'm naive maybe we
will eventually learn from Robert
Moeller's investigation what the scope
of this coordination is the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad